what is this $2 million card you bought
so it's a very special card so it was
printed in The Lord of the Ring set for
Magic the Gathering it was one card one
card supposedly Wizards of the Coast
please do not print another copy of this
card um so it's a one of one and it was
supposed to be like the actual the ring
one ring to rule them all and then the
darkness behind them it's almost like
the Willy Wonka um golden ticket so it's
just like you keep opening up candy you
keep opening up candy and then one guy
will just find it and it's like oh
and there was a beautiful man from
Canada who came to a show and he said
hey I have the graded card and he worked
at Costco he wanted to raise some money
for charity so I was like you know what
it I'm going to buy this $2 million
piece of cardboard